Speaker 1: I'm not going to spend a ton
of time on this, but Mike Pence has put
together a number of appearances here connected,
of course, to the book that he has written. And he
you know, he's turned on Trump. He's abandoned
Trump. Pence has put together a list of five or
so very calculated statements that he repeats.
One that we've heard often is what Trump did
was reckless on January 6th. Another one that he
repeats is he endangered my family. These are not
accidents. These are workshopped lines where
Pence knows he's going to get these questions
and he works with a team to figure out. Here's
the things I'm going to say. A new thing that
he said yesterday on Fox News was that there will
be better choices for the Republican nomination in
2024 than Trump. And one of the most interesting
things about this is watching the Fox, Fox and
Friends hosts figure out how to deal with this.
Speaker 2: I honestly believe that we'll
have better choices come 20,
24. You know, I don't think
anybody questions that Donald Trump. I do. Yeah.
Speaker 1: We will have better choices than Donald
Trump. So the question still remains, of course,
if the nominee in 24 is Donald Trump, will you
vote? Vote for him? I have no reason right now to
believe that the answer is no. I think much like
William Barr, who criticized Trump up and down
for a dozen different things. And then when it
came to, well, but would you vote for him if he's
the nominee? And he's like, Well, yeah, Democrats
are a disaster. I'm not voting for a Democrat. I
think despite all this, despite Pence's anger that
Trump endangered his family, he still hasn't said
If Trump is the nominee, I will not vote for him,
and I think that he will. One other interesting
anecdote from yesterday's interview with Fox.
He talked about, I guess my understanding
is this is the last time he spoke to Trump.
Speaker 2: And I went into his office and I after
he made inquiries about Karen and Charlotte,
who'd been with me at the Capitol the entire
time on January six. All the way till four in
the morning. Yeah. He asked me. He asked me what
I'd felt that day and I told him I was angry.
We had our differences, and seeing those
people ransacking the Capitol infuriated me. I
my my only thought was not this not here, not
in America. Right. But we I was very candid
with him. We were very straightforward with each
other. I sensed in the president as a right of
genuine remorse about what had happened in the
days that followed, that we spoke again and
again in the two weeks remaining of the events.
Speaker 1: What's funny about I sense genuine
remorse is as recently as last month or two
weeks ago, Trump made clear he doesn't have
remorse. He repeated all the same stuff that
infuriated his followers about Mike Pence. I
also Trump has never expressed remorse about
anything. None of this all seems made up.
Speaker 2: But on that day that you ask
about, I sense the president was still
saddened by what had occurred. And I just
reminded him, as I had at the beginning of
our first conversation, that I was praying
for him. I prayed for that president almost
every day during our administration, and he
was dismissive about it at first. It don't
don't bother. But then as a few minutes later,
as I got up to leave the room, I looked at him
as he said at the end of the little table in
the dining room, just off the Oval Office.
And I said, Well, I guess there's just two things
we're probably always going to disagree on.
And he looked up at me and faintly said, What?
And I said, referred to my role on January six.
And then I said, I'm never going to stop
praying for you. And he looked at me and
and said, That's right. Don't don't ever
change. Know that we parted amicably.
Speaker 1: Does anybody believe that story? And
the biggest lie seems to be the last thing. We
parted amicably. Trump doesn't part amicably with
people. He just doesn't. I don't believe a word
of that story. So it's an interesting
anecdote because it's the opposite of
everything that we know Trump to be. He wants
to sell books. We'll see what happens in 2024